calles desoladas mientras ucrania se
prepara para un ataque inminente en la
región del donbass
el ejército ucraniano está listo no
podemos predecir cuándo sucederá
exactamente tenemos información de
fuentes occidentales dicho esto el
enemigo casi ha terminado la preparación
para la operación ofensiva de disney
western chat dato quier como washington
han hecho la advertencia desde hace más
de una semana mientras que las tropas de
moscú se han fortalecido en el este tras
su retirada de la región de kiev así se
ha visto en ataques como el de la
estación de tren de crematorio o con
tanques recorriendo las calles de bolt
novak a los combates se concentran en
mariupol la capital de facto de luv las
de donges separatistas respaldados por
rusia señalaron que la ciudad portuaria
es uno de los principales objetivos
militares
el punto más candente sigue siendo
mariupol donde el enemigo ha concentrado
sus fuerzas en empresas industriales
el estado mayor general de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas afirma que rusia está
intentando tomar el control de mariupol
mientras que el presidente mencionó a la
urbe para pedirle armas a corea del sur
dice adquirir mariupol está destruida
hay decenas de miles de muertos pero aún
así los rusos no detienen la ofensiva
quieren hacer de mario por un ejemplo
para intentar software en el bus pocas
pocas hojas ni tienen mixto
moscú por su parte sostiene que no
parará sus operaciones militares para
sentarse a negociar como dicen que sí lo
hicieron en la primera ronda de
conversaciones
después de que nos convencimos de que
los ucranianos no planeaban corresponder
se tomó la decisión de que durante las
próximas rondas de conversaciones no
habría pausa militar mientras no se
firme un acuerdo final
moscú acusa a occidente de querer dañar
las conversaciones mientras refuerza su
presencia militar en el este de ucrania